Diese Tiere sind einzigartig auf der Welt:
ein Pferd ohne Hals …
eine Katze mit menschlichen Zähnen ...
und eine Kuh mit Pfoten.
So würden Kinderzeichnungen
im wirklichen Leben aussehen.
Der britische Designer
Tom Curtis hatte die Idee,
eine Welt zu schaffen,
in der die Fantasie von
Kindern zur Realität wird.
Die erste Zeichnung,
die ich zum Leben erweckt habe,
war ein Porträt, das Dom, mein Sohn,
von mir gemalt hatte.
Ich wusste irgendwie schon,
dass es ziemlich grotesk werden würde.
Er malte ziemlich lange daran,
so dass ich schon sehen konnte,
wie es sich zu diesem
schrecklichen Bild entwickelte.
Hier ist also die Zeichnung und
so sieht die echte Version aus.
Ich glaube, als meine Frau Becky es sah,
dachte sie,
sie hätte die falsche Person geheiratet.
Tom Curtis begann mit seinem Projekt
„Things I have Drawn“ –
„Dinge, die ich gezeichnet habe“ –
2015, als seine Kinder
Dom und Al noch kleiner waren.
Ihre Zeichnungen von Tieren,
Monstern, Autos oder Menschen
haben ihn inspiriert.
Mit Hilfe digitaler Techniken
verwandelte er sie in überraschende Bilder.
Was ich an dem Projekt so besonders finde,
ist, dass es Kinder
dazu ermutigt, kreativ zu sein.
Es gibt so viele Ablenkungen
da draußen in der Welt,
Computerspiele zum Beispiel.
Doch hier geht es nur darum, dass Kinder
zeichnen, einfach auf einem Blatt Papier.
Die Ideen für die Zeichnungen entstanden oft
auf Ausflügen rund um Cheddington,
dem Heimatort der Familie,
einem Dorf nordwestlich von London.
Tom Curtis und seine Frau haben ihre Kinder
ermutigt, sich kreativ auszudrücken.
Die witzigen Bearbeitungen ihres
Vaters haben sie dabei motiviert.
Ich finde es wirklich komisch,
aber auch cool zu sehen,
wie meine Zeichnungen
zum Leben erweckt werden.
Wir wussten nicht,
dass unser Vater unsere eigenen
Zeichnungen mit Photoshop bearbeitet hat.
Das hat uns also sehr überrascht.
Was als Familienprojekt begann, ging
innerhalb von ein paar Jahren um die Welt.
Zuerst waren es nur Freunde, die ihm die
Zeichnungen ihrer Kinder schickten.
Tom Curtis kreierte aus ihnen seine oft
skurrilen Versionen.
Dann begann er, seine Vorher-nachher-Bilder
auch auf Instagram zu veröffentlichen.
Heute erhält Tom Curtis rund
100 Zeichnungen im Monat
von Kindern aus aller Welt,
die sich eine 3D-Version wünschen.
Die besten Zeichnungen sind die,
die wirklich naiv und unschuldig sind.
Und bei denen man sieht,
dass ein Kind ganz viel Fantasie
reingesteckt hat,
um diese Kreatur zu erschaffen.
Rund 15 Stunden dauert es,
eine Zeichnung zu „verwandeln”.
Tom Curtis hat Kunst studiert und
arbeitet als Kreativdirektor in einer Agentur.
Die Bearbeitungen macht er in seiner Freizeit.
„Things I have drawn“ ist
wie ein Hobby für ihn geworden.
Ich habe zum Beispiel
dieses Auge vom Originalfoto
und platziere es hier neu auf dem Bild.
Dann zoome ich hinein, damit ich die Details
sehen kann und sicher bin, dass es gut passt.
Und dann kann ich es
auch ein bisschen verschieben.
Und so wird aus einem Kaninchenfoto
ein Wesen aus der
Fantasiewelt eines Kindes.
Auch wenn seine eigenen Söhne
langsam zu alt für das Projekt sind:
Dank der Zusendungen aus der ganzen Welt
wird Tom Curtis auch weiterhin
gezeichnete Kinderfantasien
spielerisch Realität werden lassen.